so erkennen sie fake shops tipp 1 achten
sie immer auf ein impressum
also ist dort zum beispiel eine
telefonnummer genannt eine firma mit
adresse und die liegt nicht vielleicht
irgendwo in den auf den karibischen
inseln oder sonstwo dann ist es halt ein
job den man möglicherweise vertrauen
kann aber wirklich vorsicht wenn es gar
kein impressum gibt oder die adresse ist
sonst wo tipp 2
googeln sie nach erfahrungen über den
shop andere user werden mit sicherheit
im internet kommentare hinterlassen
haben und sagen vielleicht vorsicht bei
diesem shop ich habe meine ware nie
erhalten und jetzt nur ärger ganz ganz
wichtig tipp 3
vorsicht bei super schnäppchen keiner
hat was zu verschenken und wenn
plötzlich ein iphone so massiv günstig
ist dann kann das einfach nicht stimmen
also wirklich niemand hat etwas zu
verschenken da wirklich vorsichtig sein
tipp 4 ganz ganz wichtig niemals per
voraus überweisung bezahlen das geld ist
weg und sie wissen überhaupt gar nicht
ob sie das geld jemals wieder bekommen
und die ware die kommt vielleicht auch
nicht also tatsächlich lieber
kreditkarten nutzen paypal wenn das
möglich ist wenn es nur vorauskasse gibt
dann lieber nicht bestellen und tipp 5
ganz wichtig sind sie reingelegt worden
von irgendeinem fake shop dann erstatten
sie sofort anzeige bei der polizei